the film experience is as I said began
many years ago 38 or 39 years ago in the
version that I teach and it has
undergone almost a continuous process of
transformation one of the ironies is
that it began its career in an era
before there was any technology
available to support film study it made
things actually very awkward but it was
also in some ways convenient for the
professor what we used to have to do was
show the film we used to end in fact MIT
belonged to a group called the
university film Study Center a group of
institutions included Harvard and Yale
and what we did was we had a library of
16 millimeter prints of classic films
and we circulated them so you had to or
alter your your syllabus so that the guy
at Harvard was also able to do Keaton
because there was only one copy of the
general available so it was very
complicated and but we all managed to do
it and then at while I was at MIT that
system became moribund became available
and films became available on videotape
and we began to be we also began to be
able to project them on videotape so we
didn't have the problem of trying to
rent the movie at great expense or to
belong to the film Study Center and try
to keep these 16 Milly's fraying 16
millimeter prints in operation so that
was a great boon it also allowed us for
the first time to stop and start the
text so it allowed for forms of close
reading of the media that had never
existed before and one of the things
that exposed was the errors of older
scholars and older critics who were
working from memory in describing films
because in order to write about a film
in the old days in the days when I began
to teach film you actually had to
project a movie than they were and they
had scholarly versions of sixteen
millimeter and and and other kinds of
projectors that would allow you to stop
and start things so you can study things
they were fairly expensive and you had
to go to an archive that had the that
had the material film the advent of
videotape transformed media study and
transformed film study in ways that are
still not fully clear because every film
scholar any place in the world was able
to get his hands on important text and
that process has of course been
elaborated
and the almost infinite number of times
a tremendous number of times over the
over the past decades so that today
people can go online and virtually get
access to certainly two clips and too
many older older films that were never
available before in every University and
every every film class has access to
this material and can even set up as
we've the first as we finally done at
MIT a system in which students can
actually video stream films to their own
laptops at will and that's another
wrinkle because that's a very recent
addition to what the film course did so
in the beginning we would have a
communal viewing and it was the only
time the students could look at the film
they couldn't even get a second look at
it then we move to a phase in which we
continue to have the communal viewing
but we made videotape versions of the
tape of the film's available on reserve
for students who wanted to write papers
or to review for exams then we move to a
phase in which when video when DVDs were
available we would sometimes not only
project the film from DVDs but we would
also make both tapes and video DVDs
available to students for use after
class and we would also allow students
to borrow the DVDs and watch them in
their own time and not attend the
communal viewing if they were unable to
attend and of course that immediately
set in a process began a process of
attrition in which fewer and fewer
students found time to come to the
communal viewings this is partly a
function of the scheduling crisis at MIT
and the busyness of our students if they
have an option to do it in their own
time they will often do so so that this
what had been a kind of sacred space in
the course the eight to ten evening slot
that I often use to show the film
experience text became less and less
well attended and this had the also
troubling effect of a slight and I say
maybe more than slight but at least a
slight decline in the attendance at the
evening lecture because the way I taught
the course was I had one lecture at four
o'clock from 4:00 to 5:00 they would
break for dinner or their sports
activities at seven o'clock I would give
an introductory lecture and at eight
o'clock this communal screening would
begin
communal moment before the advent of
streaming and before that was easy for
the students to get access to the text
on their own was a much more powerful
moment than it has become and so the so
we haven't figured out what to do we
haven't we haven't exactly figured how
the course can evolve in ways that can
maximize the students opportunity to
look at the material in their own time
but also maintain a sense that there are
certain spaces and times during the day
that are devoted to our activity just as
there are for their physics lab and just
as there are for their chemistry lecture
we've got to do that if we can maintain
it to maintain our parity with with the
sciences
when I begin the film experience I asked
the students to do something they find
increasingly difficult in the old days
if this this request was hardly what
wasn't necessary in quite the same way
in the old days before the proliferation
of smartphones and visual media all over
the place and everyone being able to
make his own video and so forth and the
you know the ubiquity of DVDs before
those days I was able to tell the
students look we live in an audio-visual
age we live in a televisual age I want
you to think that stuff away I want you
to get think yourself back to an age
before people understood that there is
such a thing as a film and think about
the original meaning of movie is go back
to the roots meaning it's a metaphor
that is a dead metaphor for us but it
actually it's it tells you what the most
fundamental aspect of the movies were
for the original audiences and why they
were so fascinated by the capacity of
this new technology to capture motion it
seemed like and it was a tremendous new
advance in technologies of the
representation of human experience
because it captured humans in motion
captured the movements of the world and
the firsts films as I try to show my
students were so preoccupied by this
wondrous capacity of the medium that
it's almost the only thing they filmed
and you can see the evolution of the
medium embodied in the way in which
after an initial profound fascination
with the novelty of movement begins to
wear off other properties of the film
medium begin to be discovered so I tell
my students this principle and I asked
them to try to think their way back into
the attitude of these first viewers who
didn't know about the visual media to
play a kind of thought experiment today
it's much harder to make them play that
experiment because I have to tell them
as I do in that first lecture think away
your iPad's imagine a world without
iPads imagine a world without
smartphones imagine a world without
instant communication to get an M well
and of course we're out of cook this is
much harder for the students to do and
of course at one
level they are much more audio they are
much more capable of processing audio
visual information than I am and then my
and then the my parents generation and
then and and all of the generations
older than they are because they've
grown up in an environment in which
essentially they're surrounded 24/7 by
audio visual stimuli by audio-visual
signals this many people might see this
as dangerous perhaps it is but it
develops new capacities and the and one
can see this in the history of
television in which at a certain point
there are certain kinds of television
programs that become too complex for
older generations and only the younger
general comes around 1980 with a show
called Hill Street Blues which older
fans the fans that belong to my parents
generation could watch because it had
too many subplots and it jumped around
too much but the younger generation that
was used to going to the movies and had
been watching television and had been
watching MTV they were the origins of
MTV well were able to understand this
very easily and of course that process
continued on television very intensely
so that today there are forms of
television whose audio-visual complexity
is beyond the imagination of the people
who were making programs for the medium
in the 1950s one irony of this situation
is that even though the students are
very adept at processing this
information they are even more ignorant
about the history of the medium
especially the history of movies than
ever and it's even harder today to find
students who even remember the
environment in which people had
television sets that required you to
change the channels or or who had
television sets in which you which were
confined to a single room in which in
order to watch it you had to move into
that room so so the physical environment
is changing so much and of course the
original space of the movie is the great
the communal theater that's a that's a
dying space you have to try to remind
the students about that and so the part
of teaching the film course has been
come much more historical